you've built an empire from the ground
up mr. Hale it's an honor the man who
built in New York people will insist in
your buildings make you immortal now as
you slip away do you feel immortal we
offer humanity's greatest minds more
time to fulfill their potential designed
to offer you the very best of the human
experience it's alive and empty that's
alone if we do this there's no turning
back your old life is over what's that
something is done your what it's
something to stop your heart how are you
feeling has her new body smell sense of
humor good just relax and have some fun
after all at your age I'd say you've I
work
there's money in the cars clothes you
can swallow up in the best women huh you
okay fine so feeling like they're about
52 years this was an elucidation
immortality has some side effects hello
how is this possible there is no science
no progress without sacrifice I never
wanted others to suffer I gave you what
you wanted e to the mid life no I did
soon I'll be going I can already feel my
selfie without me your mind will relapse
and we both know it takes over I'm the
only one standing between you and Olivia